what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
examining the brand-new arc that just
started in black clover and I'll be
delving deep into the character of the
newest villain
damnatio Keira the most recent events in
the story including the events
surrounding the magical Congress and
damnatio have set the stage for the new
arc and damnatio has now been fully
introduced as a ruthless Inquisitor type
villain who is threatening to end
Austin's magic knight career and to
stomp out his dream of ever becoming the
wizard king all of this says a lot about
where the story will be heading from
here and I will be talking about all of
it right here in this video if you
enjoyed the black clover content on this
channel and you'd like to see more
please leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
please don't forget to subscribe and
turn on all notifications by hitting dad
notification bell a big thank you to all
of our enemy upper patrons who make
videos like this one possible I'll talk
a bit more about patreon at the end of
the video but now let's talk about the
story and of course this video does
contain black clover manga spoilers
we're talking about the latest
happenings in the story so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned chapter 217 is called scales of
justice and it starts off with a
beautiful colored drawing of Sucre aka
Nero and I personally just really have
to stop and admire the artwork on this
page it's really next-level stuff the
chapter then picks up a few days after
the epic battle between the knights and
the elves and the devil austin Sucre are
entering the courthouse of the magic
Congress where they were invited to
testify about what really happened
during that epic battle going into the
magic Congress hasta is an optimist as
usual and he's sure that if they explain
everything about the elf Massacre dl3
incarnations and how the devil was
defeated everything will work out fine
however even before entering the magic
Congress sacré is far more skeptical and
she cautions austin not to let his guard
down and you better believe that sucre
was right because the very next panel
shows hand
and indeed both austin sucre were
immediately placed in handcuffs upon
their arrival at the magic congress the
magic congress is apparently the very
center of justice for the clover kingdom
and yet as soon as austin sucre entered
the magic congress they could see what
was really happening the Inquisitor
damnatio Kyra introduces himself and
immediately calls for a hearing for the
crimes of Austin so despite the fact
that asta was summoned there with the
assurance that he just needed to testify
so basically was told that he was just a
witness who can help shed light on the
mysterious events surrounding the elves
and the reincarnation hasta was actually
treated as a criminal as soon as he
entered the building there was never any
intention of hearing a stew out and
trying to understand what really
happened with the elves
instead hasta was identified as a
criminal from the get-go and this
so-called hearing is nothing less than a
full-blown criminal trial against him a
trial that he obviously had no chance to
properly prepare for the people inside
the magic Congress building including
King Augustus Keira clover assume right
away that Austin must be guilty and they
even haunt him for being a low-class
orphan from the forsaken region they
start insulting him for being filthy
low-class garbage without any mana and
at this point the true injustice of the
magic Congress and this entire charade
of justice is revealed despite the fact
that hasta played a major role in
actually rescuing the kingdom from the
devil no one inside the magic Congress
is interested in any of that none of
them are interested in the truth instead
they're all ready to condemn hasta at
the drop of a hat
just because he is not a noble like them
sacré is also accused of being a
criminal because there is no record of
her being born anywhere within the
clover kingdom and the horns on her head
are proved that she dabbled in forbidden
magic but of course we know that there
is no record of sakra because she was
actually born more than five hundred
years ago and the reason she has horns
is because she used forbidden magic in
order to seal away the word magic devil
five hundred years ago which saved the
entire clover kingdom these people
should be thanked
astha and sucre they should be giving
them a parade but instead they are
insulting and berating them
the obnoxious nobles inside the magic
congress have no interest in hearing the
truth and they have no interest in the
fact that both of the individuals that
they are accusing and insulting
literally saved the entire kingdom on
two separate occasions as you can
probably tell these shameless Nobles
definitely made me pretty angry and I
was pretty damned frustrated while
reading through this chapter asta tries
in good faith to explain to everyone
that the magic Knights who had turned
against the kingdom were actually
possessed by elves and that all of this
was orchestrated by the word magic devil
but Asta's words are completely ignored
by the nobles who refuse to listen to
anything he says simply because he is a
commoner at this point the arrogance and
ignorance of the nobles seems a little
over the top in my opinion like we get
it the nobles are stuck up and they
dislike commoners but Tabitha is really
laying it on thick in this scene
if these Nobles were really this stupid
and ignorant all this time the clover
kingdom should have collapsed long ago
imagine ruling a kingdom but being this
misinformed and having no desire
whatsoever to actually get informed
about what's happening in the very
kingdom that you are supposed to be
ruling
sacré is surprised that despite all
julius is hard work in promoting a more
just and fair society there is still so
much prejudice and discrimination even
here in what is supposed to be a court
of law and as I said I'm surprised too
because I find it hard to believe that a
kingdom where the ruling class is so
blatantly incompetent could survive for
this long
damnatio that approaches austin whispers
something to him and it seems that he
does this in a way that no one else can
hear except for hasta damnatio says that
either hasta will be judged for being a
devil or the magic Knights as a whole
will be the ones who will have to
shoulder the dishonor of everything that
happened
hasta again tries to explain what really
happened and how they defeated the devil
and that the devil was behind everything
but them natio asks where is this devil
damnatio demands that asked to provide
actual evidence that the devil was
behind everything but austin Sacre are
unable to do that as a result
damnatio says that if there is no proof
that the devil exists then they will
assume that there was never a devil to
begin with meaning that each person who
turned against the kingdom as a result
of being possessed by an elf will be
punished
damnatio starts out by bringing out
Marie adlai Ghosh's pour an innocent
little sister who is brought out in
front of the magic Congress scared and
in handcuffs
Austin Sacre are shocked to see how low
damnatio is willing to stoop using an
innocent child as a bargaining chip in
order to force a false confession out of
hasta damnatio says that unless they can
prove that a devil exists and was
manipulating the situation Marie will be
assumed to have acted the way she did
out of a grudge she had against the
upper and ruling class for her family's
fall from grace damnatio says that Marie
must be judged and as a bunch of hooded
figures are about to zap her with magic
hasta is forced to intervene he assumes
the black asked the form and protects
Marie from the magic attacks but because
he had to take on this form to do it his
demonic side is revealed asta says that
he doesn't recognize the so-called
Justice of damnatio and the magic
congress in the chapter ends as damnatio
proclaims that they will never see eye
to eye with the likes of a devil we are
told that the battle over the devil is
now beginning and it is pretty clear
where this arc of the story will be
going from here although he was
introduced in the previous chapter and
even then he was pretty sketch in this
chapter damnatio was directly revealed
to be the next villain of the series he
is an Inquisitor type figure who claims
to uphold justice but is in reality
willing to do whatever it takes to get
his own way he simply assumes that what
he is doing is just and he is willing to
do anything no matter how wrong any
moral in order to get his way he
believes that hasta is bad news because
of his connection to a demon and in
order to get a confession out of asta he
is willing to lie mislead and even abuse
an innocent child like Marie
addley we can also see that despite the
best efforts of people like the first
wizard King and Julius prejudice and
discrimination still run rampant in the
black holder Kingdom
and their entire justice system is
clearly a joke at the end of the chapter
I'm left wondering what is going to
happen to Austin now not only do the
nobles already hate him for being a
commoner and an orphan with no mana but
now that he has revealed himself to have
an anti-magic power that is connected to
a demon I can only assume that they are
going to want to see him publicly
executed it seems clear that this new
arc will focus on the internal divisions
within the clover kingdom and especially
the divide between the stuck-up and
willfully ignorant nobles and the people
like hasta Yami Julius marijuana etc the
people who put their lives on the line
to protect the kingdom regardless of
background
damnatio is going to use the corrupt
institutions of the kingdom to try and
destroy asta and anyone who sides with
him and the good people of the kingdom
will have to stand up to damnatio this
could lead to some form of civil
conflict within the clover kingdom
because we know that many of the Royals
and especially the most powerful Royals
like King Kira clover are some of the
worst offenders when it comes to
senseless discrimination so changing
their minds it doesn't seem likely it is
possible that the other Royals who have
more common sense like the Vermillion
family will step in and try to bring the
kingdom back on track but whatever
happens a showdown between the corrupt
ruling elite and the protagonists of the
story who just saved the kingdom from
the devil seems to be imminent
let me know what you guys think are we
heading towards a civil war within the
clover kingdom and if so is this civil
war going to be the thing that motivates
one of the neighboring kingdoms such as
the diamond or spade Kingdom to invade
the clover Kingdom which will eventually
lead to another war arc also what do you
think will happen to Austin now are they
going to try to execute him banish him
torture him let me know down in the
comments it's always a pleasure reading
your input and feedback if you enjoyed
the black clover content on this channel
you want to see more you can leave a
like to let me know and if you happen to
be new to anime uproar please don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications unless you turn on all
notifications you're not gonna be
notified YouTube is gonna bury our
videos and you're going to miss them you
can follow me on twitter and instagram
at
anime uproar for all the latest black
clover news and updates I want to give a
big thank you to all of our anime upper
patrons for supporting our work and
making our videos possible a special
thank you to all of our pro hero to your
patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
King zelgius and on hell crews on Epic
thank you to all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including baby ray ace
Ingrid ah Aloha Adam Maddy Mac
makoto-kun and keelon and finally at the
pinnacle of interdimensional greatness a
tier reserved only for legends a massive
thank you to Regan Harrison and Lord
Noxon or disciples of Lord we go himself
if you enjoy our videos and you think
they provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon link in the
description even a single dollar will
give you access to our exclusive patron
only discord and your name will appear
in our videos along with these amazing
people as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time see us
bass cowboys
[Music]